I became in 2016 and because of a deal
done by a guy called George Osborne and
another guy called Boris Johnson they
removed the operating Grant from London
so we get zero money from the government
to run public transport countries like
Germany are providing support to their
cities giving them money to reduce
public transport fares we've had no
support from the government in fact
taking him taking money away from London
my name is Sadiq Khan I'm the mayor of
London and I've been told this box is
full of anonymous questions I've ever
seen before and I'll answer as honestly
as I can
why does London receive more funding
than the North listen that the way the
question is phrased is gives a
misunderstanding about London our
Capital uh City so our Capital City
contributes every year about 42 billion
pounds to the treasury net so we give
back to the center far more than we
receive which is distributed around the
uh country but look London's population
is around 10 million we're about six of
the countries are population we
contribute hugely to the countries they
do to us as well as a two-way
relationship what we shouldn't do is
play off London against the rest of the
country it's London with the north not
London versus the north I think the
government this government and the next
one hopefully the label one should be
devolving more powers and resources to
Manchester to Birmingham to Liverpool to
Scotland to world and to London the
current living wage in London is 11
pounds 95 Pence do you think this is
enough to sustain a life in uh London
it's a really important question so let
me just explain so the the London living
wage is 11.95 Pence an hour it was nine
pounds 40 Pence an hour when I first
became uh man it's been increased hugely
over the last few years the government's
National living wage is 10 pounds 42
Pence an hour so our living wages far
higher in my view it's still really
difficult for londoners to make ends
meet in this great City it's really
difficult for londoners to keep the head
above the water let alone to flourish
and uh Thrive and there's a number of
reasons why it's difficult called the
cost of housing is so expensive in
London landlords can evict tenants
without a good reason if the tenant
complains about any issues in the
accommodation often the rents go up in
between uh tenancies but also we know
the cost of living is really expensive
with energy bills and so forth so we've
lobbied the government to freeze rents
in London in Scotland they've done it uh
in London if we did it we'd save the
average person renting privately at
three thousand pounds over at two years
we're building more generally affordable
homes in London more Council homes than
any time since the 1970s more homes
completed that anytime since the 1930s
we think the government should give us
the powers to set up a commission to
look into having rent control in London
because for the foreseeable future I'm
afraid in the short to medium term even
if we massively ramp up the amount of
genuine affordable homes we build the
supply is not going to meet the demand
so rents are going to stay high and let
me see the problem with that we're
losing Talent from London if I was
speaking here at 15 20 years ago I'd be
saying Porters cleaners bus drivers
can't afford to live in London they
still can't but now as journalists head
teachers police officers senior doctors
as well as others in the NHS can't
afford to live in London that's good for
nobody and that's why we need to build
more gender affordable homes and have
more protection for those renting
privately rank the London Tube lines
from best to worse that's a cracking
question that's from my mum I think it's
regularly asked me so when you're the
mayor tube lines are like children you
can't have a favorite
anybody's got children will know what I
mean by by that but there are some lines
that are that are great my favorite tube
line though I'm going to give you a
favor one is the one I use every day
which is the northern line I remember
the northern line I live in South London
where it was called the misery line
because it's just awful we've invested a
huge amount in the northern line to make
sure it's set for purpose I think the
worst line according to many people is
the central line because of a lack of
investment over decades it's hot a lot
of it is underground and it leads to
rural temperatures that are really
difficult for people the second line
that people use that they say is not
great is the bakery line the bakerouline
trains are from 1971 they're the oldest
trains in the country when we need a new
part this is a true story uh the the
company the factory that makes the parts
is no longer around we've got to go to
the London transport Museum in Covent
Garden to get parts from the trains
there to install on the bakery on it
that's how old it is we do we can
despite government uh Cuts but again
with government support we can invest
even more in these lines so don't forget
a lot of the a lot of tourists come to
London it's the the number one tourist
city in the world we don't need to leave
with a bad impression by lack of
investment in our Capital City you
pointed out crested I think it should be
crescilla dicks failings but what's next
for the Met police so the president was
the former commissioner of the Met
Police Service and uh you know giving
her pleasure in saying so but I lost
confidence in her because it's clear to
me that there are systemic cultural
issues in them at Police Service
actually across police in the country
so we've now got a new commissioner Mark
Rowley who has you know has my full
support as does his Deputy Dame Lynn
Owens three things that are really
important for me new commissioner uh the
the Dame Louise Casey report and the new
plan the new Commissioners are now uh
published to turn around uh London we're
going to set up a policing board for
London later on uh this year to support
the police but also to challenge the
police to make sure we address the
systemic cultural issues and let me tell
you the scale of the challenge we have
Dave news Casey found and I completely
accept her findings that the police
service is institutionally racist
institutionally misogynistic and
institutionally homophobic it's not a
few rotten apples this is about changing
the systems and cultures in the Police
Service making sure it's uh far more
difficult to for people to join the
police service if they're not fit for
purpose far more easier to get offices
it shouldn't be police officers changing
the culture of the police service so
it's anti-racist anti-misogynistic anti
uh phobic we need to win back trust
confidence of londoners it's really
important I think we're going in the
right direction but I think the new
commission reserves time uh he has said
he thinks he needs two years I think we
should give him two years I'm afraid
walking home at night what steps are you
taking to ensure the safety of women in
London it's a really important question
because unfortunately it's just a
reality I'm afraid in this country uh
across this country every three days
a woman is killed at the hands of a man
every three days one woman loses her
life and so I completely understand the
concern that women and girls have I'm
also fully aware and I say this with
humility uh that my experience as a man
are very very different the experiences
of women and girls I don't need to
impose a curfew what time I get home I
don't need to wear trainers so I can run
fast if I'm being followed I don't carry
keys in my fist so I can use it as a
weapon if I need to so there's a lot of
things we're doing to address this issue
we've actually recently launched a
campaign around this issue because I
think yes there are criminal justice
Solutions it's really important we have
more police it's really important that
the courts are more effective it's
really important that conviction for
example for rape are far higher than
they currently are so there's that angle
really important we're also got to
educate men and boys as well because the
reason why you're not feeling safe the
person ask the questions because of the
actions of men and boys let's be frank
so we're trying to encourage primary
schools and secondary schools to teach
boys about healthy relationships how to
respect girls not to be a sexist
misogynist we've launched a campaign the
theme of The Campaign is to have a word
with a mate by using the word mate all
the evidence suggests often boys and men
when they're by themselves act in a way
that could be sex as a misogynist and
often others haven't got the confidence
to call them out on their behavior and
that behavior sex the misogyny can lead
to fathers against women and girls so
changing boys behavior and attitudes
lead to them acting like better men and
will lead to you being safe walking home
in the meantime better lighting invest
in the public realm making sure the
streets are safe because high visibility
at policing but also making sure that
men can be good allies to somebody like
you who may feel unsafe walking home so
for example let me know you know if a
woman's in front of you don't walk
behind if you're a bloke it makes her
feel nervous cross the road or go around
rather than have really nervous as as
men and boys we've got to be more aware
of how women and girls are feeling
there's been a six foot increase on tube
prices this year is that fair
considering to live in no it's not it's
not fair and the reason why I had to do
it is because the government forced me
to do it what do I mean so for the first
four years when I was mayor I froze
fairs in London because of the pandemic
though a few people started using public
transport which meant the amount of
money we're bringing in from customers
dried up so we switched to the
government we need your support
otherwise be able to stop public
transport and the government said we'll
give you support financially but there's
a condition and the condition is you
must raise the fears uh by one percent
above inflation countries like Germany
are providing support to their cities
giving them money to reduce public
transport fares in some cities around
the world their government's giving them
money to have some services for free to
encourage people back to their Center
we've had no support from the government
in fact taking them taking money away
from London I became May 2016 and
because of a deal done by a guy called
George Osborne and another guy called
Boris Johnson They removed the operating
Grant from London so we get zero money
from the government to run public
transport 2016 2017 2018 2019 2020 for
the first time in history operating
costs for TFO went down on a like for
like a basis the debt
Johnson borrowed before I became mayor
far exceeds any money we've borrowed we
borrowed it because of the uh pandemic
and for the first time in tfl's history
next April I'll be able to see a tfl's
operator Surplus even though the
government's give the government's given
us no support for operating costs you
compare that to New York Paris Barcelona
Madrid Chicago Tokyo any major city in
the world get support from their
government London's tfl doesn't I can't
afford to drive because of your
ridiculous U.S policy which affects the
poorest and unreading verbatim by the
way and negatively impacts life in
London during a period of soaring cost
of living so let me just unpack the
various uh false premises in this
question so in our great city of London
every year the amount of people who die
prematurely because of air pollution is
around four thousand the people who are
most likely to suffer the worst
consequences of air pollution are those
who are least likely to own a car it's
an issue of social justice around half
London and London households don't own a
car the poorest London is therefore some
of the worst consequences but it's also
an issue of racial Injustice because
black Asian Mario City londoners who at
least like to own a car suffer worst
consequence of air pollution because
they even tend to live on main roads
where there's the worst pollution so
what are we doing about it we've got
this policy called the ultraflow
emission Zone which we began in central
London and in the space of one year we
managed to reduce the toxicity the
poison in central London by almost 50
percent so we expanded it to Inner
London up to the North and South
circular and we managed to reduce
toxicity Poison by further 21 so the air
breathed by 4 million londoners in in
London is now far cleaner leading to a
third fewer admissions of children in
hospitals in outer London where 5
million londoners live is where the 10
boroughs with the highest premature
death rates are and the 5 million London
isn't out of London haven't seen the
benefits that we've seen in Central and
in London so what we're doing is yes
expanding the U.S to Outer London from
the end of August but because we're
listening to the concerns about the
person who has the question uh in on the
card we've got the biggest scrappage
scheme we've ever had in this country
110 million pounds supporting low income
families supporting small businesses and
supporting Charities when I first
launched this policy only 39 of vehicles
39 Vehicles were compliant the great
news is now it's 96 compliant cars
inside inner London and more than 90
compliant cars in outer London which
means they don't pay a penny but they
get cleaner air
from basic stuff like lack of PPE to not
ordering the face mask to not making
face mask compulsory early enough had
the government acted sooner and acted uh
in a different way I think fewer lives
have been lost